this animation is brought to you by
skillshare an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for
creative people
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
a coronary angioplasty procedure is also
known as
percutaneous coronary intervention
the procedure is done on blood vessels
called coronary arteries
they supply your heart muscle with
oxygen
the goal is to restore blood flow if a
substance
called plaque has significantly narrowed
these vessels
to begin the procedure the doctor will
numb the skin in your groin
a needle will be placed through your
skin and into the femoral artery
next a flexible guide wire will be
passed through the needle into your
artery
then the needle will be withdrawn
it will be exchanged for a small
flexible tube
called a sheath this permits access into
your artery
you may feel pressure when the doctor
inserts the sheath
but you will not feel it moving inside
your artery
next the guidewire will be advanced up
to your heart
a flexible tube called a catheter will
be advanced over the wire to your
coronary arteries
the progress of the procedure will be
checked with an x-ray device called a
fluoroscope
at this point your doctor will remove
the guidewire
then the doctor will move the tip of the
catheter just
inside the coronary artery to be
examined
a special dye will be injected into the
artery this allows your doctor to view
it better with the fluoroscope
the dye will make any blockages in the
artery stand out
if a significant blockage is found your
doctor will insert a guide wire into the
artery
a balloon on the tip of the catheter
will be moved along the wire to the
blockage
the balloon inflates it will expand the
artery
and improve the blood flow you may feel
some chest discomfort while this is
happening
after this your doctor will deflate and
remove the balloon
a wire mesh tube called a stent may be
placed in the treated area
the stent helps keep the coronary artery
open
your doctor will choose the proper size
stent which is compressed over a balloon
the stent will be moved into the artery
over the same guidewire
when the balloon is inflated the stent
will expand
and lock into place
after the balloon catheter is taken out
the stent will stay in place to hold the
artery open
at the end of the procedure the guide
wire will be removed
to find out more about coronary artery
angioplasty
talk to your healthcare provider
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creatives
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads
and they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
if you want to learn how to use the same
software programs we use at nucleus
skillshare has hundreds of courses for
you on cinema 4d
adobe after effects and zbrush they
offer courses on how to create
micrograph images in c4d
so your cellular animations look
realistic and cinematic
and much much more take advantage of
skillshare's free trial for premium
membership by clicking the link below in
the video description
sign up and explore your creativity